[Music]
and rejected romance news I'm rejected
submitted by it hmm they love straws
burglar flooded a woman B&B after she
rejected his romantic advances Wow you
robbed a persimmon Hellmuth no that's
not like a bull [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ]
no so this man he was uh he was a
painter and a decorator for this woman's
bed and breakfast and he professed his
love to her and she really much miss you
[ __ ] Stan Segundo 3 the pain of every
race is the sixth place in the you cage
maybe damn Mexicans are not a home yeah
uh his name is Kevin
by the way oh my Monday no I partly oh
good Oh with angle sighs ah he wants to
be partly mala
I don't here have Mexican decorators in
which sometimes you don't want places
every day like I did I don't
Kevin profess his love to Cassie and she
rejected an saying she doesn't have same
feelings he does another Sun watch and
so um because of that like because of
her reject akin stuff like he started
acting really inappropriately so she
reduced his duties to the point where
like you just she just backed down
pretty much factum like fired him
oka yeah I'm not in bed second one so so
anyway so then she ends up going to
visit some family members and she gets
phone call from her neighbor saying that
her house has water coming out of his
legs being flooded and so she gets there
and she discovers [ __ ] some damage to
her property
so this is her bed and breakfast oh wow
is that are there multiple units in here
or is that one giant house that looks
like giant house it looks like a [ __ ]
castle dude man I fell in love with her
too
I know I know why fellow there's this
caffeine system of damage oh he left the
shower heads on the floor in the
bathroom and just left the water running
on permissible purpose like he broke
into her house to do that but what did
he get caught though like wouldn't
people just know who did it
yeah yeah he does nice house because he
got caught right heard of course yeah so
he did confess to everything and he said
that it was because he got really drunk
and he was really heartbroken because
rich old ruined all of your chains and
hope that makes it okay yeah so he cause
like if you're heartbroken you could do
whatever you want and he was drunk so I
probably peed in the shower at the same
time for extra British Lord John Henry's
I know wait till you said he's a burglar
so what did you steal ah that's what I
was trying to figure out but I think it
was broken tooth out I think they really
Oh because of the fact that he broke in
he's a trespasser yeah exactly
and he also like removed the keys from
like all the doors so police couldn't
come in to like stop the flooding so I
keep really planned it out
wait so there was no one there notice
she had left to go visit family also
she's like closed it for that time yeah
do you think the most softest
passive-aggressive person I've ever met
[Music]
what would you do this should happen
happens to me all the time really just
time the people that are madly in love
with me and I I just tell them I don't
have that kind of time right now
what if they flood your car then the
inside of my car yeah then I guess I'll
have a swimming pool while I'm driving
to work that's the way to look at it
maybe he was just trying to add a
swimming pool that she always is well I
didn't side the property as all have a
snorkel that sticks out of the window or
the moonroof you know what made me think
of like so it probably didn't go down
like this
but it reminded me of Jumanji remember
when the water goes throughout the whole
[ __ ] house and it gets all sick like
oh my god yeah
that would be awesome that would be so
worth like water damage assistance you
more yeah if you could experience that
like they're seeing here on that yeah
like a Mont like a raging waters inside
of your house yeah I would fix it and
then I was telemedia mm-hmm or you could
just build your house like that in the
first place if you get a lot of money
you just kind of like water in your
house no I mean you would waterproof
your house first so that you could like
surf out of it somehow you know oh [ __ ]
it's kind of like you know where you go
you know Universal Studios Hollywood
right
remember that [ __ ] cowboy thing where
the [ __ ] pulls up and then they flood
the whole thing oh yeah looks like that
so it's main to do that you could press
a button and the whole house gets
flooded but then it drains away and then
it comes to back up again so you can do
it again and again that's a great idea
Michael furnitures all rubber bed rubber
I know couches rubber so it could
sustain the one
don't be the best way to wake up
everyone yeah imagine that's your alarm
clock you're in bed why the worst way to
wait on red and you go down the
waterslide yeah so it's all going to be
like oh it's raining I'm cold turned
away take it away you know I bet I feel
like that's what's going to happen after
the first time that it happened to Joe
it's like a morning shower no I like
your concept I think for mine I think I
would like to have a robot instead of
like all this water coming of robot just
gently cradle me
out of bed don't be realistic and then
carry me into the perfect temperature
water and then just wash me while I'm
still sleeping and address me get me
ready and then I don't know you just
want three hookers why three have you
girls ever experienced like a guy that
profess to the love and then when you
turn them down then they try to harm you
or sabotage you not harm but they just
got angry that's it yeah how what
happened Roger Locker or a lot no a
boyfriend peed on his shoe I like it was
a dude in college and like I like I told
them Cheryl you know I for a long time I
thought that like you know crush on me
and then she played off like oh no I
never did until one day he decided to
ask me out on a date and I said no and
he told you to have a question on me
[ __ ] yeah and then he was like
why don't you just give me a chance and
I was like because I'm not interested
and I'm telling you I'm not into her
give him a chance Julia cuz I wasn't
interested in what was wrong with them
he had mad yellow fever so and she was
hitting me every day asian girl there
didn't feel special well you wanted to
be the only Mulan he had weird ideals
too because like you'll be like like so
who call me up really randomly right and
you're like look all my binding no he
was all like the summer school classes
and I was like what my Plymouth hymen
ready yet and he was like oh ha just
kidding and I was like [ __ ] it he was
like what cautious do you plan on taking
I'm like I don't know and he was like
okay yeah just cool is cool so laser so
like for for a homework assignment what
was the measurements right and I was
like oh it's like this said meters by
this centimeters like centimeters I only
have an inch ruler and I was like just
convert their measurements and he was
like oh I thought this is this what you
got and I'm like
these are the measurements I'm going to
use he's like okay cool cool
yeah I'll totally use that and then
learn me like other type of who like all
me BHA and like who'll try to help me
defeat costed me about like how all
these like other girls that he's
encountered like they only like guys
that have money or that have cars and I
was like dude bro I think you're just
looking for wrong girls and he was like
why what's your type and I'm like well
I'm not telling you he's like oh come on
I told you what my type was and I was
like yeah that was your choice and it's
my choice to not tell you so that's for
me to know and not for you to know what
was his type a little buddy Asian
do he even like till this day from what
I hear from my other friends is that
he's still hitting on this one chick
that's had a boyfriend for a year and
he's still telling her that he's no good
runner like that her boyfriend oh good
for him and that she should date him I'm
like what oh yeah there's a lot of weird
people as well I don't know how going
yeah you got angry of y'all like dude
back off and you girls ever experienced
that Oh like then was like trying to
hurt me or anything I did have an
experience with Tiff's can't say no so
she'd never know you just got with him I
did me that's why I was the into deep
girls because there was at one time I
did reject like a close friend of mine
and he really liked me and I was like oh
like how did he tell you you bought it
with spray paint I know everybody's
always only have succumbed in his
[ __ ] rape before I love you
yeah but then after I saw your name on
the lawn with his armor what did he do
I don't remember right you just told me
I was redirected him and but I didn't
like him out of the nicest way I could
because you know me I hate confrontation
being mean to people so after that like
I thought I did pretty good and I was
pretty nice and then a hue like stop
talking to me completely started
spreading rumors about me and like
telling other people I was a [ __ ] and I
said this and that and I don't know what
and I was just like what
Beverly your close friends lose my
neighbor to yourself I took oh that's so
weird yeah anyways this guy Kevin he was
handed a 20 month prison sentence and he
also has they say he's suspended for 18
months along with a rehab requirement
suspended me like you gotta do his job
anymore
yeah so does the golden Condor at
Christmas family probation oh and then
he also has a restraining order placed
against him to stay away from Kathy for
five years so man what's up with all
these are smugglers man they're all
[ __ ] weird dude
especially dude you know what this
reminds me of guys that get rejected
though I [ __ ] you I don't watch a
[ __ ] number anyway [ __ ] yeah it's
like you're just like idolized you just
like watch so weird I know what [ __ ] you
I watch your number anyway take a look
like how loser like how are you gonna
win her over you're talking [ __ ] haha I
don't know either it's they're so
desperate for posting it's so crazy they
like trying to act like they know what's
best for you and they try to kind of
control that mmm
cuz they away you know what my niece
actually went through something like
this so she went to a banquet right and
then she was telling me about like her
day and she's like yeah I don't feel
like I'm gonna kiss until I'm married
and I'm just gonna let that out there
I'm like that's good you [ __ ]
communicate everything you just I don't
wanna I don't want to kiss until I'm
married and I don't want a boyfriend
until way later in life because you know
we have so much life to live and
experience to all like damn good Koreans
[ __ ] tall right and I was like so you
think do you like him or not Jose nah
he's not competent and I might mmm good
good only go for the confident ones and
close yeah because he doesn't have an
opinion you've always just agreeing with
me all the time and trying to like say
the same things I'm saying
and I even flipped it on him too and I
said one thing and I contradicted myself
any agree with both I'm all like that's
right that's my niece that's good and in
all sentence you like but then he still
likes me
and you know somehow he thinks that I'm
eventually going to get with them and I
was like well you tell him that you
don't get with little [ __ ] like I'm
like that's right you tell them that
I'll go prob 13 or 14 yeah I like that's
right you don't go hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if you guys want to share a
story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]